[Music]
oh
okay hi i'm grace pelvic if you did not
know that i know your life is different
now
i'm here with mamrie heart and hannah
they are moms today i figured you'd zoom
in yeah
it's march and st patrick's day happens
in march and for the last i don't know
how many years
on various youtube channels i've been
shotgunning beers on st patrick's day
my taboo
no good no no go you can't
no fear of a ghost
i drank it all i didn't even open my tab
yet
but i thought let's switch it up a
little bit because in reality
none of us really drink beer true you
know you love
i still love beer beer to me is the
you know the partner that makes you feel
like [ __ ] about yourself
i once bonged a beer funnel that came
from a second story this year we're
switching it up and
it feels like lately every time you guys
are on my channel i just make you
participate in some sort of game so we
have a game today
a game that i'm calling back huh huh
i like that yeah yeah that's usually how
i feel about the next day
yeah i'm all what did i do last night
drinks vodka
and the rest is just a blur we are all
very
big fans of vodka soda so i thought you
guys might be really good at this game
in which
you guys are kind of blindly tasting
four different vodkas
and you're gonna see if you can tell
which brand of vodka it is
because i have very very low level taste
in vodka but a lot of people have really
high level or
top shelf taste in vodka and to me they
don't taste any different
so maybe you guys might be able to
figure out if they do
this will be good because mamrie is
always good at everything
yeah it knows the taste of everything
that she wants is if everybody's
competitive
she does it all but mamrie doesn't like
straight vodka from tempaka i'm not an
80 year old
russian man stop leaving those comments
yeah yeah yeah so get off my dating
profile
what i'm not good at is knowing the
difference between
taste like yeah i remember when we were
in new york yeah was it and someone gave
me a sip of like
80 year old wine like and like a 3 000
bottle of wine gave came over and gave
me a sip because it was my birthday
30 30 promo and i went this tastes like
shoe dirt yeah i was just like and
there's like
that was 400 you just spit on the ground
right now no i'm not good at this
okay i'm basically making you guys play
this game because i want to play this
game i'm just excited to get started
i contributed no commentary because i'm
like do they taste different so we'll
start with number one it's your first
glass here so we don't know the list of
brands we just have to guess okay
would you guys want to know what's the
brand no no no no no okay
i can't smell anything that's good
that's a sign of vodka i think it's a
sign of either goodness or cheapness
i'll put the four bottles here that i
bought
velveteer whoa you've splurged cheetos
it's lauren
doley's also i personally i feel like
that
personally actually i feel like i looked
at the prices cheetos and skye are the
same price
and stoley is second so you're fooling
yourself slowly
yeah i mean work on your packaging
because yeah and also this is plastic
this is glass but these are also
airplanes
but look at that intricate drawing okay
with belvedere strolling
tito's and skye number one have a sip
which one do you think it is i'm getting
no nose it's not wine is this a wedding
reception because i'm getting no bouquet
i think it's got a little bit of a
crispness to it the finish is short the
finish
is short you can describe it all you
want i have no idea
what any of these actually look like
each round or can we go
through i think you should go through
however you want to taste all of them
and then
and then we like say our thing okay
so that's your first one okay wait i had
okay so let me think i did the respect
definitely pepperiness no scent and a
very short finish for me
okay did you just give your tinder
profile move on number two okay oh i'm
like about to get so
red on this video the whole video is
just gonna be black and white the whole
time don't worry let's just say
this might be my cheetos guess
i'm thinking
number three hold on let me just keep
track what grace i'm sitting no i'm just
sipping
randomly to see if they taste different
are you subconsciously slipping the ones
that we're on i don't know i honestly
don't know talking
okay honestly delicious okay now i'm
beginning to realize that vodka doesn't
really smell like anything in general
yeah that's very cool
also if you guys need palette cleansers
because i feel like it might be
a little bit nope okay so number three
got you good
number three number three you guys are
having two very different reactions to
number three
i'm a vodka drinker i like vodka i enjoy
vodka but come on number three could
start a monster truck with one flick
i'm sorry i don't understand what you
said northern california
versus north carolina i went to high
school parties with straight up white
lightning and that thing just made me
flinch with white lightning
moonshine oh my god ready number four
oh wait a minute old friend or favorite
you just broke up with that old friend i
hate it i'm
scared guys we haven't drank all of
these vodkas no
number four is bad try it memory you
threw up thank you for that clickbait
thumbnail you're welcome
it's terrible but you guys go ahead
place your bets
make your guesses belvedere stole keto's
guy the most expensive
to least expensive there's no way to do
this
oh wait so these are yours from okay i
got mine oh wait no no no what do you
think
wait wait wait wait wait hold on i'm not
at home let me clean my palette oh wait
one
okay don't move these yeah i have mine i
think
positioning makes no sense different
methods i don't understand we say what
we think number one is
yeah okay what do you think the first
one was that you sipped belvedere tito
you can't change your answers just so
you guys know yep number one is skye
oh you thought
the first one you drank was skye vodka
which was the cheapest vodka i like the
sky
best in order of my wow okay so what no
my system is flawed you're correct yeah
i told you can you remember what is what
okay what did you think the second one
was that you drank i should have i
thought number two
was tito's i thought number two was
belvedere number two was build the deer
five one point one point what did you
think number three was i thought number
fee was stolen wait what did i do i
don't know i thought that was belle
i thought she knows oh number three yeah
i thought that one was stolen
oh no no no no no sorry i got three with
skye three was
cheetos yeah i had that wrong i had them
all run
[Music]
four stolies which one did you spit out
i spit out four
four stoley is what i had what'd you
have i had four skye or a stolie
but it's also more expensive than tito's
and skye oh my god
i enjoyed sky the most probably because
it's mostly water
but wait they have the same alcohol so
one can't be mostly water
they're all 40 bucks alcohol they just
have a different distillation oh i do
think belladoo is very good my two
favorites were these guys maybe i should
switch the sky instead of two though
these are my too faced yeah i like
cheetos the memory you won and this is
your gift it's up
[Applause]
yeah i actually do want to see if you
win because i spent five dollars on it i
think i have some quarters in this that
tip jar i have any quarters in here
do i just go for all of it i got another
i don't know how to play play area on
right to uncover
18 weeks an 18 wheeler 18 wheel numbers
we might have to cut back to this
i don't know how this works you want two
hundred dollars we'll come back to this
on social media to see if memory
actually won this scratch off ticket and
make sure you go follow
hannah and mary on youtube because we
shot two other videos on their channels
they're really fun
hopefully this was helpful to you i
think we might have did this completely
wrong so
congratulations to future grace editing
this video i'm really proud of you for
making it to this point good luck with
your
vodka i don't know
stripes aren't just like and she's got
one really low boob
awkward proportions happening right now
don't worry if there is a clothing line
called
awkward proportions i would buy
everything i won't react let me just
look it up what it actually does
it's our it smells like um cinnamon buns
i'm roasting the squash for us oh good
oh
god you just brought so much elegance to
this video
i'm roasting the squash i can't wait i'm
not a metaphor
i'm a belvedere girl who knows
and this one can suck all the time he
was stalling i mean no there goes all my
possible brand-new